[Music]
good evening everyone and welcome to
this Southeast planning committee
meeting on Wednesday the 15th of
November
20123 my name is councelor Vanessa Bell
and I'm the chairperson of this
committee members We Believe live
streaming this uh meeting live as well
as recording fingers crossed and by
being present in the meeting you are
giving your con sent to being recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak and I
will then invite you at the appropriate
time we I ask members to avoid
approaching the top table as this could
create interference with the cameras and
live stream good luck
approaching please note that YouTube
live stream sound recording is dependent
on the correct use of the microphones
therefore can I ask that when invited to
speak you speak into the microphone we
don't have have to turn them on and off
here and um members of the public when
um when I invite you to speak I'm going
to ask you to come speak into one of the
microphones please I I will do that in
the appropriate time good evening
Council
stand please reference a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers and please keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible okay item two apologies for
absence I believe we have nine talk is
that right that's correct we haven't
received thank you thank you okay moving
on to item three minutes of the previous
meeting which was held on 20th of
September
2023 and these can be found on pages 7
to4 um members I so mooved that these
are approved do I have a second up thank
you councilor
nil
um does any member wish to raise a
matter of accuracy councelor
Haywood okay
okay thank you can we record that Clark
somehow does that get
amended yes disree everyone we can put
that
in MERS by with Y thank you okay um can
we agree the minutes by C members please
with that
Amendment super thank you very much
Declarations of Interest item four to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
registerable interests and
non-reg struggle this non registerable
interest interests relating to items of
business on the agenda having regards to
paragraph 9 and appendix B of the code
of conduct for members and members I
must remind you that you're also
required to disclose any such interest
as soon as they become a aware should
the needs need arise throughout the
meeting members any Declarations of
interest of course you can canel think
you just got here in time so thank you
of course
no thank
you okay so agenda item five we have
00135 which is an outline application
land at Bells Gate molden Road lingon
cm36 LF and you can find this on pages
15 to
26 we have no members update with um on
this item so we'll go straight to uh Mr
Lawrence if you could present the report
please thank you sh this application
site is the remains of a dwelling in its
curtilage and it's located on the
Eastern side of molden road outside the
settlement boundary of lendon the area
to the Northeast and south of the site
is characterized by open agricultural
Fields the area to the west across
molden road is characterized by a range
of dwelling types and mix of commercial
and Industrial sites and also com that
all form is to the Southwest of the
site two um the planning history of the
site is in important that it has
previously been approved by this
committee to Grant outl planning
permission um that was granted on the
2nd of March 2020 under refence 19 Str
01214 this permission lapsed in March of
this
year so just for again this is a
slightly different view of the property
here you can see this is development to
the south of the site and you have the
Open Fields to the east of the
site um as I said this is an outline
application all matters are reserved um
I would just add there is an existing
access to the site um that is prob an
indicative plan of of the dwelling could
go there so just to
give remember some context of the site
this was previously you see that it was
a shell bangalow um I think it burnt
down in the late
1990s um you can see there's not really
much left for the burn but there is
there is still the four walls walls are
still standing um and there is a
detached garage at the side of the
Propet um this again is just showing the
context this is the property again back
that's back to this slide an area of
views so you got all form here this is
the B
108 the site and it Li to be decent and
you can see the Open Fields so on the
S so this is a view this is the view
looking from The Junction with the 1018
looking to the North and the Lower Side
is the side down is looking down to the
south towards the road
Junction context to the
site that's the last side as I said
previous previously inform has been
given an outline that is a material
consideration the council has approved
the consent for the rebuilding of the
property that as I said it is a material
consideration that it is um it is
entirely outlined the only conditions
that the other conditions there would be
conditions which would restrict the
height to 7even meters that's because of
the existing building you can see was
upon below there do appear to have been
rooms in the roof and there's also a
condition that the EES height should not
exceed 3.5 M and first floor
accommodation shall only be located in
the roof space um this application is
recommended for
approving thank you Mr Owen so yeah
recommended um for
so um which way yes
[Music]
C I
understand
[Music]
but
reality
[Music]
sit understand
that being the cas how do we
find however what we're really agree
today is not the
application
[Music]
off S
to
policy and
does
situation
[Music]
come for
are so given the
fact I really can't
[Music]
see to
First in terms
[Music]
of develop pretty
much the harm that is done is
to a massive for any development to come
in
that I justen to
right well okay I problem if we
to and
increase
[Music]
okay do I have a
second councelor stand Council basser
councelor stand thank
okay I yes please Mr I just might make a
comment obviously every application has
to be be treated on its own merits and
if permission were to be granted it does
not mean we would have to Grant one in
if if there were similar circumstance
each application is looked at
individually what also we have to be
aware of in terms of the consistency in
decision making is that there has been
an outline planning permision it was
granted by this committee and that is
that is a that is a stum that does way
in favor of this
application I mean I
don't
[Music]
will
just
and signit build that
number I would
[Music]
agree
umus back
thank you councelor Pratt and councelor
laage
which was
St in the middle of the Cs the cops was
down
Theos a lady of nearly 0 was to the
inquiry and she remember as a young girl
she used to stay with her father we ends
and it was Pro was
resid um and they r
cost us a lot of
money
and to balance
things
[Music]
yes
thank you coun
coun
yeah oh thank you can's done and then
[Music]
cancel
and
just to
2019 and it wasn't just polic policies
the
government4
district
[Music]
and9 um I actually I'm going to
support
recomendation
to because we are set president
and and we all know what's happen when
we
have
ites one or
houses many houses because the
Pres I don't see that this is a special
it's that's been identified have like a
development plan I specialist housing or
affordable housing this is just this is
just
a thank you councelor stamp councelor
FL
[Music]
just
we are
are
[Music]
question
I know I used it only the other
day
well yeah I would make the and so you'd
be happy to Second so let's take this
one first does anyone else want to speak
or shall we take Council fitted
proposal
so all those in favor of refusing this
and going against the officer's
recommendations please raise your
hands councelor passenger councel ftic
and counselor
stamp all those
against
okay so that is not carried so uh I
shall then make the proposal that we
accept the officer's recommendation to
approve do I have a second councel fluka
so all those in favor
members one two three four five seven I
think I the count and all those
against that's three so thank you so
members that application is approved
thank
you in line with the offic
recommendations thank you very much
members so we now move on to agenda item
six
0044 another outline commission for
lands north of Willow Grove molden Road
mundan and you can find this on pages 27
to
44 of your
pack we have no members upd date again
um in relation to this so I would go
straight to Lisa Greenwood who is
presenting remote what is
Greenwoods thank you chair this is an
out
application reserve for future
determination except the need of access
for the elction of up to two drings the
site is located approximately 1.2 km to
the northwest of the S could you slow
down bit
Mr could you slow could you slow down
okay thank you an application with all
matters of detail reserv for future
determination except for means of access
for the erection of up to two dwellings
the site is located approximately 1.2 km
to the northwest of the settlement of L
and approximately 1 km to the southwest
of the settlement of mundan the site is
outside of a defined settlement boundary
and is in open
Countryside the site is neighbored to
the north and Northeast by an employment
use- plant limited this is a production
firm that serves the Horticultural
industry to the South is R Grove a
residential dwelling the site is
surrounded on all remaining sides by
open Countryside and the character at
the site is rural there is no existing
access there is also no footway to
connect the site to the settlements of
lingen or mondon there is also no Street
lighting at the section of the highway
and the speed limit here is the national
limit of 60 m per hour as it is
unlit members detention is drawn to the
fact that planning permission was
refused for the erection of two detached
drings with integral garages new access
driveway and garden out buildings this
was a full application the application
has refused for six reasons notably the
s's outside of a settlement boundary and
safe access cannot be provided to the
nearby settlements and future ents would
be heavily reliant on the car the
proposed design would cause har to it
character and beauty of the open
Countryside The Proposal was not
supported by an up toate eological
survey and insufficient information have
been provided on how to secure a net
gaining
biodiversity the application was not
supported by satisfact human Val
undertaking would therefore have an
adverse impact on European designated
sites it was also not supported by tree
Ser members should also be made aware
that the applicant has appealed the
decision of all the district council and
this appeal is still live
the council is not yet in the seat of
the inspector's decision and is not yet
aware as to the position the inspector
will take with regards to the reasons of
refusal most notably the location and
suitability of the site for residential
development which also applies to this
application objections to the scheme
were also received from residents in the
neighboring dwelling and the commercial
use Dash PL
pack returning back to the proposed
subject of this presentation as part of
this application a new access and way
are proposed the footway is outside of
the red line boundary and proposes to LT
the site to a bus stop to the Northwest
the applicant suggested this could be
imposed with a gring condition however
as the application has been found to be
unacceptable in other regards this is
not been pursued here are some
photographs of the
site that's the front of the
site the neighboring use and that's
looking from the site towards the bus
stop
it is not considered that the proposal
although outlined has overcome the
previous reasons for concern regarding
the accessibility of the site design and
impact on recreational disturbance while
some of the technical issues have been
addressed for example up to dat true
reports have been submitted the site
remains located outside of a defined set
of boundary and safe access cannot be
provided for pedestrians and cyclists to
the nearby settlements future occupants
will be highly reliant on the car
further lend and mundon are smaller
Villages and do not provide the level of
employment facilities and services
required for day-to-day living the
proposal proposal would also cause an in
congruous form of development is out of
keeping with the
countryside in sufficient information
has also been submitted with regards to
the S Cas recation disturbance avoidance
and mitigation strategy and the
necessary Financial contributions have
not been secured with regard to noise
the technical objection has been
received from the council's
environmental health officer o to the
site's close location to Desh limited
future occupiers may be exposed to noise
and other nuisances which would be very
difficult to control and it may well be
that the firm has an Agent of Change
defense against such complaints the
reasons outlined the application is
therefore recommended for refusal thank
you chair thank you very much M
Greenwood Mr L do you have anything to
add okay lovely so we do have some
public participants so first of all I
will invite um Julia Osborne to speak
please if you could
um approach the microphone thank
[Music]
you thank you m you have two minutes so
whenever you're ready we'll set the
time bear
with
okay whenever you're ready thank
youire property will be imped by this
proposal
Justified our concerns
include
number
[Music]
essential but we have no guarantee this
will be maintained into the future
regardless
the
includ
or development we are very concerned
about disturb having
and OB our curing activities including
[Music]
Machinery thank you very much well in
time thank
you okay if I can now invite some Han
Taylor who is a supporter to
speak
yeah sorry
we' we've got three speakers on this one
cc
stamp okay just hold one
sec okay so 2 minutes whenever you ready
okay I'm using my two minutes to respond
to the first proposed reason for refusal
mainly the presumption that future
occupants would be heavily reliant on
using a car this is not correct I've
lived in L for 47 years my parents moved
into Willow GR in 1980 and quickly
became active in the local community
on and when they they gied this piece of
to
us becoming more restricted and my days
of easy walking and driving may not last
much longer however I do not believe
that Reliance on the car would be
inevitable in this location there is an
excellent bus service which goes past
the door which will give me access to LA
and Burnham or mden chelsford and beond
I could safely walk to the nearby bus
stops particularly if the proposed foot
will do instead of driving I'd avoid
congestion and parking problems i' be
and for me the bus is free it's a means
of transport of considerable importance
here even if there were to be a usable
foot to L I would not be able to use it
safely I find it hard to walk there
comfortably the cars are narrow and
often overgrown and in any case the
frequency of the buses means I'll
probably be overtaken by walking my
current property is only accessible by
steps and following the Unexpected death
of my husband last year I'm now looking
for more suitable accommodation ideally
a house where I can live on one level
where my children are a stay I'm also
aware that such a move would free up a
much needed three bedroom Family House
on state opposite the local Prim I've
lived in lington a long time and the
traffic now busy noisy unpleasant and
full of Lo the traffic on the bur mod
however remains unchanged and the road
is quieter which will
it spot G keep your mat
[Music]
done okay thank you very much and
finally can I send the applicant Mr
Bishop
please so whenever you're
ready I'd like to address the SEC
proposed reason for ref our propos is
effici use of
overed the says should promote and
supportment land this especially
identified needs for housing do
regarding the character and context the
dominant fure is the large Factory
sitting in the middle of this continuous
linear mix group buildings it's an
active location with nosic beauty the
factory continuously behind our and
overlaps the back of Willow and our site
is already surrounded by existing
bu our propos will
not it does not
the Beyond
beond unaected
have
by
back
well
trees
the access will match will the proposed
public footpath is an obvious compliment
to the highway and would sit univ within
the ver propos the planners have refused
to discuss this and even stated it's
part of the reason for refusal despite
Pro Highway our proposal will be
entirely in with the local character in
the context of its surroundings
compatibly with its neighbors and not at
all in Congress in this setting there
are no objections from any expert statut
cons final design detail design will of
course be agreed at Reserve matters and
there will still be a visual gap of over
40 m between our building in the factory
with the large perers and other trees Ro
and open green space no evidence of any
harm has being presented to the council
by the council and the officer actually
States in their appeal statement twice
that overall any harm cause would not
out weigh the benefits of the proposed
SCH we believe that these
re
spot inside again thank you very much Mr
Bishop thank you I'm you called in
councel F I don't believe you've moved
house have
you
resp
[Music]
Miss greenw did you catch that I think
so so with regards to
Rams um I don't believe we rece any
additional
information um so I I don't believe that
that reason for refusal would be
overcome with regards to the foot
path that would obviously be a matter
for highways um as well to be involved
with and with regards to the appeal
statement um the appeal is still live so
we we don't yet know the position but
our position remains that the benefits
would not outweigh the harm so so as you
all aware we have a high bear housing P
this site is outside of the settlement
boundary um it is likely that to the the
pond and the access you might be able to
get a dwelling on there um but the the
contribution of that one dwelling would
be would be nominal um and having
visited that road again today myself um
it is a busy road um and there are
better locations within the district for
for that dwelling so so I think the the
harm the benefits would definitely not
outweigh the harm in this instance
so are you able to do that sorry um I
can't
hear Sor some sound issues if you could
speak up
Council
um I I would have to go through the
appeal statement
but
I'm I don't have that in front of me
um I I don't believe that the council
would
Mr La I've got I don't have it I mean I
can access the
[Music]
file
I could we could
def we could it I'd have a look at the
paper M are you happy to adjourn briefly
or should
[Music]
def
why
in made that
decision that appeal we're not here to
debate and and talk about the appeal
we're here to hear this
app I'm going to go to I'm Mr I just I
mean obviously we have to determine the
application that's before us this
evening mhm yes there is what said in
the appeal but you have to concentrate
on the the application it's recommended
for refusal there's been a clear report
by the officer you have to determine
it what's before you now thank
you
I'm going to make um sorry yes Lisa you
have your hand up thank
you um I've got well I have the letter
in front of me and it says the benefits
are considered to be
negligable um overall and taking into
account the points made within the app
statement the inspector is respectfully
requested to the appeal not withstanding
ISS contain to the letter then there are
conditions suggested
um I would say that the I mean Mr
Lawrence the matter before us is this
application yes and this appeal is live
um you know as Council has just said
yeah no thank you I'm going I'm going to
I'm proba to dismiss that Council fler
and I'm going to go with what we have in
front of us so um any other members like
to comment thank you m GRE
yes
Lo the
[Music]
har and again I repeat I before we are
just being pushed around by developers
and actively
saying
[Music]
have
and
[Music]
thank you Council any other members if I
can just what council fedck has said
obviously the time if if we are to
change the boundaries that is for a
review of the local plan we've now had
legal opinion that we do have a 6.35
years housing land Supply therefore our
plan is not out of date it complies with
the mppf therefore the settlement
boundaries are shall I say that now they
are back in they are in they are part of
the local
plan thank
you nobody
El
consider so when
we
[Music]
don't
was
to
so
sense The Proposal coming
on
but you know
honestly
[Music]
thank you do you um is there a second
for that y
councelor okay anyone else like to speak
on this yes councelor
[Music]
again
I
mean about pres
I if we
keep
[Music]
thank you very much um yes counselor how
you with that counselor
St
itic thank you thank you can stand can
go
backos yeah we've just got that and then
we take
that yeah
coun counil FL let's let's let's go to
um first of all councilor fluker's um
proposal
to
thank you let's go to um the vote though
so those in favor of the The Proposal to
approve which is against the off officer
recommendations please raise your
hands Council fluka Council label all
those
recorded can we minute that please um
that councelor fluka and councelor
label well object to thank you and um so
those
against
so that proposal Falls so then we have
um councilor stamps some proposal that
we refuse in line with the officer
recommendations so members all those in
favor please raise your
hands two three four five six seven
eight yep eight and all those
against and that's two so uh we are
refusing in line with the officer
recommendations thank you members so
that brings us on to agenda item
seven which is on pages 45 to 56 again
no members update on this so um I will
move straight to if you're still still
awake
and quietly please if you could present
your report I do believe
Mr thank you thank you and good evening
members this is a reserve matters
application for the approval of layout
appearance Landscaping scale following
the approval of outline planning for
motion for the Redevelopment of the
culture f for approximately 5,000 square
me of employment
space now outline plan was outline
Planning Commission sorry was granted in
October 2020 for the development which
approved principle of development so the
use of the site use and the access has
um in terms of the application site it's
located to the south
of maping Chase um runs along the
northern boundary of the site um and it
serves the number of properties
including residential dwellings and open
storage use and the
pratorum bes access through mine
industrial estate the m road and that
serves a number of commercial units and
also residential property the details I
think agreed and the site
outside so this is a site plan that's
been submitted with the outline sorry
with the reserve matters application and
the proposed development is for five
buildings on the site of varying sizes
they're all the same height me to the
ridge um and 4.5 m to the EES um but
they are different in terms of footprint
and they're arranged as shown on the
site plan not very easy to see the gray
shows the building on that
plan um unit one is to the north of the
axis as you go in 15 to 18 on the
southern part of the axis with the other
buildings around the edge of the
site the overall footprint of the
building is just under 5,000 sare m so
that's acceptable in terms of the
outc 138 spaces CES are proposed on the
site 19 spes
andion parking has also been
sh um what still on
that um it's considered that the
development would be acceptable change
of
ision if caring is in accordance
withing
standard you'll see there is addition
recomended requiring a charging points
um andec The
recation Right Moving On thank you um
I'll just quickly rattle through the the
these plans because the buildings all
look very similar um they're fairly
functional design with dual pitch and
elevations and half brick with metal
cading above um as you'll see as we we F
through the the design is very similar
if you can just move on the floor CL and
then the roof CL and then the for the
other units I've just combined those
just to give a quick
view here the Landscaping plan just
shows fa uniform design and a function
design um it's considered that the the
layout of the development and the the
appearance of the buildings is
consistent with that the surrounding the
area so there's no objection in
that Landscaping is another res matter
hard and hard and soft Landscaping
scheme is things submitted for approval
and've got the
detail as well um there is a large area
of Time s to accomodate path and
vehicles just for this of develop
however there
areos you just
go post press here in terms of location
let's make it
Chase on the right side here that's just
within the site system building that's
at the top Chase
and again some sort ofing effect Chase
thank
you so just coming to the summary um it
is considered through the upline plan
commissioned the principle and the
access it's considered that there aren't
any impacts onor properties and in terms
of Vis impact and a lot
those
um so the application is recomed for
subject
condition thank you very much members
over to
you oh sorry I do I'm so sorry I'm
looking at your name on my so we have
done the the applicant um I was great
please and we will get the uh time ready
so whenever you're
ready
good evening this planning application
seeks to agree the reserved matters
following the outline plan Commission in
2020 for the r development of culture
providing commercial units and
Associated access this commission agreed
the principle of commercial development
here the matters now submitted include
layout scale and
Landscaping the layout proposed involves
five separate buildings which differ
separated by access areas car parking
and also areas of
landscaping in terms of appearance and
scale development provide under
[Music]
5 and this
the the
maximum comprehensive Landscaping sche
has been submitted which includes 30
trees
and and
ORS
planting are also
ined and of these
pled on the land and the council
standards this development would be a
benefit to the rural economy providing
employment opportunities for local
people and bring Associated economic
benefits consisting of
businesses matter sign in accordance
with the provisions of theine plan
commission and the council's aded
policies
as thank you very much thank
you I no council
stamp can I just ask to some more
information and what has led to the
officers who have
recommended approval when you've got
holding objections from County Council
regarding um and theology consult can I
just actually ask what do
to
rec accept not believe forgive me
acceptable in planning terms that you
think that's when you've actually got
those because they are St to consult and
I've been told many many times years I'm
looking at you should not
necessarily
against we do usually say exactly that
so this one's a little bit different
because we're gr an outline plan that
was subject to a number of
conditions some of them included things
like subs and there's another condition
included
including now both of those conditions
are precent conditions which means that
the details have
subed development
Comm um in this case it's slightly
different because the reserve matters
application doesn't require or
trigger those details for these subm
with it so we've got an objection from
the the local flood authorities they
want more
details there is a condition out trans
specifically with that we've got the
same with the ecologist there holding
addiction wanting some more
information and again with' got commen
condition requiring those details to be
submitted so that's why in this case
it's slightly different so we're not
ignoring them those details are still
absolutely vital and and could result in
a different scheme being reported for
example theology came back and saying
measures needed a completely different
layout for example then we have to come
back in terms of Reserve Mees as well
but that's why in this case we aren't
ignoring them or or anything like that
we're saying they will be dealt with a
different
time so based on that then so if these
conditions aren't um um done applied or
whatever the
um then the application would be
withheld with it and it wouldn't go
forward until the conditions were met so
it isation cannot go ahead until all
these Comm yeah but
okay
it's interesting
prev I think it's
Prett wow we've been here before I think
certain
applications is that
second I think members are falling over
themselves to agree that so can we agree
that by a senate members yeah agreed
super thank you so that um is um
approved in line with offic
recommendations excellent thank you very
much so um
that brings us on to theend of item
eight any other items of business that
the chair considers urgent I have none
so members at
2033 I close this
meeting thank you
all